In the new movie "The Batman," Bruce Wayne
quickly meets and partners up with Selina
Kyle, also known to DC fans as Catwoman.
The two have an intensely intertwined story,
with Bruce helping Selina uncover the fate
of her roommate and the truth about her father,
Carmine Falcone.
But there's one other important figure in
Selina's life who plays a key role in the
film's story — and she never even shows
up on screen.
This is her mother, Maria Kyle.
Selina explains her backstory to Bruce one
night, telling him about how her mother worked
at the Iceberg Lounge and met Falcone there.
Of course, then this romance led to her, and
she spends most of her early childhood years
just hanging out at the establishment.
As she talks about her history, it becomes
clear that a lot of what she does is based
around this past experience.
While she might claim to want to get away
from Gotham, Selina can't seem to leave her
connection to Falcone and what happened to
her mother behind.
It's obvious that Selina loves her mother
very dearly, leading her to take her father's
abandonment more personally.
Then, when her roommate ends up dead in a
similar fashion as her mother, Selina's drive
for answers grows even stronger.
But casual fans of the DCEU tuning in to watch
"The Batman" might not know a lot about Selina's
backstory, and there's a lot about her mother,
Maria, that the movie doesn't go into.
In "The Batman," viewers only really know
anything about Maria based on what Selina
describes to Bruce or Falcone.
But with all the information the movie provides,
it appears that this version of Maria is a
loving mother who is just unlucky in life.
Maria works at the Iceberg Lounge both before
and after giving birth to Selina, but unfortunately,
she is murdered when Selina is very young,
and for a long time, Selina doesn't know who
is responsible.
Without a real direction in life, Selina grows
up and develops the thieving skills she exhibits
in the movie, intending to steal some cash,
leave Gotham, and start over.
Aside from her career and relationship with
Falcone, "The Batman" doesn't reveal too much
else about Selina's mother.
But one thing is crystal clear, and that's
the fact that Selina clearly loves her mother
very much and holds no resentment or bad feelings
over how she grows up.
Instead, all of her grief, hate, and loneliness
is targeted at Falcone, who she knows is her
father but who has zero involvement in her
life, leaving her to grow up all alone after
Maria's death.
In the comics, Selina's relationship with
her mother is a little more complicated, and
if you can believe it, a little more traumatic
too.
As revealed in the solo series, "Catwoman,"
Volume 2, which ran from 1993 to 2001, when
Selina was a child, her mother Maria was in
an abusive marriage with Selina's father,
Brian Kyle.
At one point, Brian says that Maria's family
are refugees, possibly from Cuba, and she
likely speaks both English and Spanish, something
Brian berates her for.
Along with that, Maria suffers from mental
illness and faces money pressures to support
the family, which includes a younger sister
Selina doesn't have in the film named Maggie
Kyle.
Unfortunately, Maria dies by suicide when
Selina is very young, and she is the one to
discover her.
In the aftermath of her mother's death, Selina's
father turns to drinking and she is eventually
separated from her sister, leading to her
growing up on the street and taking up thievery.
Luckily, Selina holds on to one connection
to her mother in the form of gymnastics, which
her mother enrolls her in before her death.
Selina exhibits a natural skill for gymnastics
and it clearly helps her later on once she
becomes Catwoman.
In the comics, there's also a rumor that Carmine
Falcone and his wife Louisa Falcone are Selina's
real parents, though it's never confirmed,
and of course, the film makes it clear that
Falcone is at least her father.
Relating to that, the comics don't show if
or how Maria and Falcone could've crossed
paths, although their connection is a major
focus of Selina's story in "The Batman."
If you or anyone you know is having suicidal
thoughts, please call or chat online with
the National Suicide Prevention Lifeline at
1-800-273-TALK (8255).
Or Text HOME to the Crisis Text Line 741741